AUDIENCE: One of my questions
is about GPU rendering.
And I wonder if any
of your solutions
are incorporating stuff
that OTOY is doing
or, you know, GPU
instances, is Google
planning on throwing in
graphics cards to machines,
and where are you
guys headed there.
SRIKANTH BELWADI:
OK, this is actually
one of the most asked
features of rendering.
What I can say is this is
something that we're definitely
looking at.
Currently, most
of the rendering,
at least for visual
effects, is still CPU-based,
and we're able to offer
this for burst rendering.
But GPU is something that's
definitely on our minds.
JAMES COULTER: With
regard to deadline,
absolutely we're supporting GPU.
It's supported on a
sort of per renderer
or per application basis
within our plug-in system.
But if the application
supports GPUs,
we can implement it
within our plug-in.
We already have
some-- for example,
V-Ray and so forth-- and so
you can allocate how many GPUs
and where they go and so forth.
So yes, it is there.
HUNTER WILLIAMS: We would
love to see GPUs, as well.
TODD PRIVES: I would
say we're actively
keeping tabs on where
the VFX market is
in terms of rendering.
And right now, we're looking
at V-Ray, Mental Ray, Arnold,
Renderman primarily
being CPU-based
but, certainly, as that
progresses in the future,
as [? Bel ?] said, we're
looking at everything at Google.
AUDIENCE: That seems cool.
Thanks for the presentation.
For on-demand
licensing, for example
if we used a solution
like Syncbox,
the on-demand licensing for
plug-ins and V-Ray and Maya,
I know Zinc has it, but does
it, like, for example, like,
for a solution
like Syncbox exist?
JAMES COULTER: Sure.
So obviously, the Thinkbox
model is sort of roll your own.
And we try to make it as easy
as possible to roll your own.
Clearly, the vendors
have to be on board
with on-demand licensing.
We're providing our
own system that anyone
can jump onto if
they want to, so that
makes it easier for them.
Some will and some won't.
But I think it's
undeniable, based
on what we've all seen today,
that if you're not playing
nice with the cloud,
you're not going
to be all that successful.
So a lot of vendors
already have solutions
that make on-demand
licensing work on the cloud.
And the ones that don't,
I'd be very surprised
if they don't get
on board very soon.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Question for me on-- and this
is just a general statement
if any of you guys have
experiences with this,
because we're trying to
go through it as well.
Have you had to deal with any
of the studios and the security
requirements for putting
these images up and down
in any kind of-- what have
they had you go through
for qualifications
and anything else?
Just because this is
such a new platform,
you know, and there's
really not any kind
of standards or
any kind of letters
written on how to do this yet.
So I didn't know
if any of you guys
had any real-world experience
with the studios putting
their images into the
cloud and not being secure
in that facility.
SRIKANTH BELWADI: Yeah.
I mean, one, there's going to be
a completely different section
on security data
just off the launch.
But the point is, [INAUDIBLE]
every studio considers
these assets as prized jewels.
Their business depends on it.
But it's also important to
know that for cloud, this
is our business.
I'm needing to make sure
that our customers find
that their content
is safe on the cloud.
And we make all efforts that
we can to keep it that way.
At the same time, the
industry, I'm sure most of you
will agree, is quite fragmented.
So what are those security
best practices that should be?
Each studio has its own view.
And the rating for
MPAA guidelines
to be published so that we can
demonstrate that we not only
comply but exceed the
requirements of security
best practices.
What I can probably say
is that for all the work
that on-prem security
engineers do,
the cloud as [? industry ?]
because we depend
so much on that business, what's
several orders more in terms
of investments in security.
So that's what I can see.
But I'd like to hear from
what studios like Rodeo FX
have actually
faced when they use
cloud for the real
stunning visual effects.
JORDAN SOLES: I mean,
whenever we use the cloud,
we have to get in touch
with the studio right away
and get permission.
And, surprise, surprise,
almost all of them say no.
So yeah.
So right now our cloud
usage is typically
focused on commercial
products or independent films
where the restrictions
become significantly less.
HUNTER WILLIAMS: So we're taking
sort of a two-pronged approach.
One is reactive and
one is proactive.
On the reactive side, we do
work with a number of studios
out there that have blessed us
to do certain work for them.
There are some ways that we
can not store data in the cloud
but maybe store it on site and
simply process frames and then
send them right back.
On the proactive side, we're
working with the Cloud Security
Alliance and the
MPAA to understand
what the guidelines should be
and what the best practices
should be for security.
AUDIENCE: You recognize, though,
that the MPAA is the lowest
bar.
HUNTER WILLIAMS: Yes.
Yes, I do.
SRIKANTH BELWADI:
Yeah, actually, we're
hoping that the bar would
increase because traditionally
MPAA probably was
tasked with this time
to explore physical security
of existing studios.
AUDIENCE: Both the MPAA
and [INAUDIBLE] studios
don't have a similar position.
It's the [INAUDIBLE] That has to
figure into your negotiations.
HUNTER WILLIAMS: No, I'm good.
JAMES COULTER: So
I think there's
two different
pieces, though, when
you're talking about security.
One is, is the
cloud itself secure?
I think it's unquestionable
that it is secure
because banks are running on
it, military is running on it,
movies are being
distributed over the cloud.
The cloud is secure
as a service.
But then there's the question
of how you interface it?
How do you get from
your local premise
up to the cloud and
the entry points,
endpoint attacks, and
so forth like that?
That really falls back to
just traditional IT security
that's fairly well understood.
Now there's, of course, a
few new pieces in there.
But security, of course, is
one of our highest concerns.
But I don't think it's
as big of an enigma
as people make it out
to be, personally.
AUDIENCE: I don't
disagree with you.
But I don't think that
the studios with the MPAA,
for that matter, were
based on rationality.
They're an entirely
reactive model.
OK?
If something gets
out into the wild,
they start bleeding evil as
quickly as they can find it.
The cloud is [INAUDIBLE].
JAMES COULTER: And
what you've just said
describes the internet
in general, right?
I mean, we went through
all this with the internet.
We went through all
of it with VHS tapes.
We went through all of it with
any sort of new distribution
mechanism that's
ever been invented
goes through this same
educational learning pain
process.
And we're just now coming
to it with the studios.
And we'll get
through it, you know.
We're all smart people.
SRIKANTH BELWADI: Yes.
JACK: [INAUDIBLE]
SRIKANTH BELWADI:
Can I give you one?
Oh, this one's--
JACK: Hello?
Enlighten me.
SRIKANTH BELWADI: Oh, it's you.
JACK: OK now.
Oh.
OK, my name is Jack.
I work with Uncharted Territory.
And the gentleman over there,
I worked actually with him
before.
Security is dictated
to us by the studios.
And specifically, I can tell you
when I worked at that company
before, Marvel dictated
to us what we can do,
what we cannot do.
And I can assure you, they
did not like the cloud.
In fact, they even
dictated to us
not to have internet access
to the artist workstations.
So security is very important.
I work right now on a
[INAUDIBLE] feature movie.
I know for sure cloud is a no.
I would like to
hear from you guys.
One thing is, have
you worked with them
on getting the green light
that we can use the cloud?
Secondly, who's taking the
liability in case such as,
for example, "Expendables
3" was leaked last year
in August, full DVD quality,
three weeks before the release.
Is Google taking the liability
for that if something like that
happens?
Or is it going to be
us, the studios who's
working on the content?
Or is it the studios themselves?
SRIKANTH BELWADI: Actually,
I'm seeing the very smart--
JACK: We got our--
SRIKANTH BELWADI: --security.
Judy or Matt
O'Connor or somebody.
Matt O, thank you very much.
Thank you.
You could have come
in just in time.
Before I hand over
the mic to Matt,
we are trying to rationalize
with all the studios, including
Marvel, to look at
cloud wholistically
rather than having it yes
or no binary decisions.
Right?
Regarding "Expendables,"
liability, frankly,
I do not know if any of that
has actually happened on it.
OK, cool.
Thank you, Matt. [INAUDIBLE].
MATTHEW O'CONNOR: Working?
Oh, there we go.
OK, there's a
little bit of delay.
In case I say a curse word,
they can beat me, I guess.
My name is Matthew
O'Connor, and I'm
responsible for security
and compliance products
for Google's Cloud Platform.
And I do actually have
a prepared presentation
to give you guys after
lunch and put you
to sleep after you've eaten.
But very quickly.
And we can talk
about this some more.
And I'm around all afternoon,
so I can get into details
with people who want.
Yes, Marvel has a
lot of constraints
on what they want to do.
We've talked to Marvel.
We've talked to other studios.
It's not really clear across
the motion picture industry
what a baseline standard is.
And I'll show you
a little bit later
when I give my presentation
that we address
a lot of security standards.
And on some
industry-specific stuff
that has nothing to do
with motion pictures
but might be applicable.
We have-- actually, I was at
a content protection summit
before the holidays.
And I actually made an
offer there in the room--
and this offer still
stands-- that Google
is willing to help
facilitate the conversation
with the motion picture
industry to figure out
what that baseline standard is.
And we'd actually be
willing to do it in a way
where we could also bring
the competitors to the table.
Because we don't believe
that we're the only solution
that people are going to use.
But we do believe that
cloud-based computing has
the ability to help
your industry do
some revolutionary things, do
new things, do things cheaper,
do things faster than
you've been able to do it.
And I think there's some
content that you guys are
going to be able to create
that's going to blow our minds.
But you're going
to be able to do it
because of the on-demand
nature of cloud resources.
So we've made that offer.
That offer still stands.
And then specifics in terms of
liability and indemnification.
We have commercial arrangements
with our customers.
And so obviously, if there is a
major motion picture being done
and there's some
concerns about that,
I think Google, in terms of
being a commercial service
provider, we have to address
those kinds of things
in our commercial arrangements
with our customers.
And so we have some
provisions in our agreements
with customers that take care
of those kinds of things.
Because we have banks.
We have companies that
have intellectual property
around industrial
mechanical design.
We have customers who are
delivering consumer services,
and the privacy of that
consumer information
is really, really
important to them.
And so we protect
a broad spectrum
of customers, both through
our security measures,
security policies,
but also through
our commercial arrangements
with the customers.
And so we get lawyers.
We sit down and we hash that
out and get it worked out.
And we can do it
in a way that it'll
be amenable to all
the parties involved.
SRIKANTH BELWADI: Thank
you very much, Matt.
MATTHEW O'CONNOR: Sure.
SRIKANTH BELWADI: And I do look
forward to your presentation
this afternoon.
AUDIENCE: So I have a few
concerns and some questions.
The first concerns are
generally for the studios
in terms of gauging the
amount of waste, in terms
of compute time.
It's not too often that artists
will send jobs to the farm.
And not because of
anything that they did,
but because maybe the
software that they're using
may fail on the farm.
Have you guys done some analysis
of some of those compute cycles
that may not have needed that
burn through hours and dollars,
of course, in terms
of associating
how they, with
licensed software--
part of the reason why we roll
our own cloud a lot of times
is because, again, it keeps
that liability a lot lower.
And then the second
question is really
about alternatives to Evaer
and whatnot, things like Aspera
and Google's take
on things like that.
SRIKANTH BELWADI: Sure.
Maybe Hunter or Jordan, want
to take this cost and savings?
HUNTER WILLIAMS: Sure.
TODD PRIVES: Oh.
[INAUDIBLE]
OK. [INAUDIBLE].
SRIKANTH BELWADI:
I'd be happy to.
TODD PRIVES: I mean,
I think there's
some inherent
responsibility to the user
if you're using software
and you submit a job
and there's a bug in
the host software.
So that is something
that's come up
a few times within our system.
We're certainly happy
to work with customers
if it's a bug on the
infrastructure side.
It's a little bit less clear,
and it hasn't come up that much
in terms of--
AUDIENCE: That's definitely
the studio's liability cost.
TODD PRIVES: Right.
Absolutely, absolutely.
And that's inherently
part of the risk
you're associated with
with cloud at this point.
But to be honest
with you, at least
in the Zinc
infrastructure standpoint,
we haven't seen that
being a major block.
And it's probably the
same with Conductor
in terms of the churn of hours
and the relatively few errors
that you actually see on shots.
Granted, if an artist doesn't
prepare the shot properly
and the sampling is super
high, I mean, there's
some responsibility on them.
But in terms of
the software side,
I haven't seen that high
of a failure rate where
it cuts into the actual spend.
But I mean, I would
imagine it's the same.
HUNTER WILLIAMS: Yeah.
So there's a couple of things
that we do to manage that.
The first is that we do health
checks on all the instances.
So we stream the log
files off of them that we
can detect anomalies in.
The other is that we are
constantly going around
and checking these instances.
So if their memory spikes or
we see a panic and the instance
dies, you would still
be getting charged
for a persistent disk and
some of the other things
that are going on there.
But we're going around
every 20 seconds
and checking to see
where everything is
and if it's all working.
And we also have, as I talked
about in my presentation,
we have some bread
crumbs in our code
all around so that when any
sort of an action is taken,
it writes something
out to BigQuery,
an item out there,
so that we can
track any job that comes on and
to make sure that it comes off.
And while it's
running, we can track
to see if anything
has happened to it.
So when it comes
to runaway costs,
we try to mitigate
that as much as we can
by just constantly looking back
and seeing if things are still
running correctly and
constantly just health
checking all the instances
across the whole farm.
TODD PRIVES: And
just one other thing.
I don't envision
it that differently
if you have an artist
that submits a job locally
and you are paying something
for your HVAC and for your power
to that machine.
And if it's a wasted
render, that's
still a sunk cost to you.
So I don't envision it
that much differently.
SRIKANTH BELWADI: Yeah.
Regarding your second question
about Aspera and Evaer.
We are under no illusion that
all of visual effects rendering
are likely to happen
on cloud from day one.
People have existing
data centers
and will probably use
cloud for bursting.
So with that being said,
I think our partnership
that we are just recently
announcing that Evaer
is actually very important.
People probably already have
their existing compliances,
and we have just
recently come up
with the virtual filer
that runs on GCP.
Similarly, Aspera
[INAUDIBLE] with the offering
does support [INAUDIBLE]
files from your desk jobs
or from your local data centers
to Google's Cloud Platform.
And those integration
farms are what we enable.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
This is for Jordan.
Could you elaborate more
on your SaltStack setup
and talk about maybe
the time to boot
to when the system's
actually ready to render.
JORDAN SOLES: Not really.
I don't have the--
[MIC FEEDBACK]
Oops, sorry.
I don't have those stats.
I forget what our-- I mean,
we had done instant time setup
prior to that with VMs, and
the time it would take to boot
was just not great in
comparison to what Google claims
the instances can start with.
As soon as we
started using Salt,
everything started getting
closer to the Google times
that we had seen before.
But I'd be happy to put you in
touch with somebody at Rodeo
if you have any
interest in that.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I have a question,
I guess it's about logistics.
Just like a basic
logistical question.
Do we have any
real-world examples
from any of you guys
or anyone else here
of moving data back
and forth to the cloud?
For us, that's our
biggest concern,
being able to ingest the
data quickly, especially
like a company like
I work for now.
We're working on a lot
of smaller projects.
Instead of working on one
film for a year or two years,
we're working on a couple
hundred smaller projects.
So that moving data
back and forth,
it's sometimes
terabytes per day.
We don't have the
pipe to do that.
Security and speed
don't get along.
So I'm curious just if anyone
has any real-world examples
dealing with that.
JAMES COULTER:
Generally speaking,
it always comes back to how
much bandwidth you have.
If you have large bandwidth,
you have a little bit more
flexibility.
You always want to be
intelligent with choosing which
files to push up and push down.
Compositing is often challenging
unless the data is already
up there, of course,
simply because you
have to move your
plates up and so forth.
In a lot of cases, if you're
looking at-- simulations
are a great example, where you
have a fairly small set of data
that you're uploading.
You may be generating
cash or your download
might be kind of heavy,
but generally speaking,
a lot of facilities have an
easier time getting data down
than they do pushing data up.
So you can push up data
sets that are small,
do your compute, pull the data
set down, or alternatively,
leave it up there
for the next stage.
So it is doable.
It's like so many other
things in computing,
you just have to be
aware of the constraints
and send the right work, use
the right tool for the job,
essentially.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SRIKANTH BELWADI: Should we
vote for online use case as well
as offline ingestion.
Ingestion is by far the biggest
problem for cloud computing
because processing will happen
only if the content is there.
So for the online,
the real strength
is the Google Massive Network
and [INAUDIBLE] of presence.
And recently announced
carrier interconnect.
So irrespective of which telecom
operator that you work with,
we will be able
to peer and we'll
be able to offer
the interconnect
with your provider.
We just started a [INAUDIBLE]
offline ingestion right here
in LA with a partner
called Iron Mountain.
So if you have disks of content
and you need to upload it,
you don't need to do
it from your device.
You can actually ship it
or carry it [INAUDIBLE].
TODD PRIVES: I do want to add.
I think that the perception
is worse than the reality,
oftentimes, with CG rendering.
I mean, at the
beginning of a project
is when your textures and
your large assets are coming.
So if you manage your pipeline
well, and Zinc does it
and I'm sure Conductor
does it, you're
able to parse a scene for
only the assets you need.
So as long as you're able
to move that stuff up,
generally in the day or two
or three that you're animating
or you're modeling
or doing geometry,
those large assets
are not changing.
And I know it's a
foreign concept.
You guys have to move
these massive data sets up.
But we found when we had
hundreds of customers
prior to joining Amazon--
joining Google app when
we were on Amazon, we have
many customers now in the beta.
And data I/O, I think,
is perceived initially
as a major blocker.
But once you're actually up
and in the pipeline using it,
it's not as bad.
And I would imagine it's
the same for-- you guys put
a whole feature film through.
I would imagine it's the same.
HUNTER WILLIAMS: Yeah.
We call them
incremental uploads.
Anything that changes
gets uploaded.
When we do the
dependency checks,
anything that's been uploaded
already we just skip.
And then to confirm
that it's going to work,
we pre-render the first, the
middle, and the last frame,
just to make sure that
all the items are there.
AUDIENCE: I think
that the offline idea
is really good for
smaller companies
and for studios around
Los Angeles that
are getting their feet wet.
Where we're still having to
ingest terabytes per day,
the ability to send a
runner over with hard drives
is the reality of how we're
going to have to work.
SRIKANTH BELWADI: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Hello?
OK.
I work with a company
that helps companies build
on-prem solutions, so I'm privy
to a lot of the constraints
that these guys deal with.
And there are a lot
of questions I have.
But the one question
I've got is,
we're always trying to figure
out that inflection point
of maximizing CPU utilization.
And we run into a
lot of bottlenecks
whether it's a network
or the storage.
So one thing I was
wondering is if there's
any telemetry in the VMs
that you guys are running
in the cloud that will tell you
if the CPU is running at 100%
and if there's any way to
look at what the storage
protocols that are being used
are to make sure there's not
a bottleneck somewhere else.
It's one thing to have
a VM that's running,
that's processing.
But to know if it's being
managed efficiently,
if the storage on the
back end is optimized
to handle that type of flow.
Is there anything that you
guys could talk about that?
JAMES COULTER: So I'll speak
briefly about deadline.
Generally speaking,
a VM is going
to behave the same way that
a physical machine does.
So whatever utilization you
see on a physical machine,
it's going to mirror on a VM.
Additionally, in the
case of deadline,
we have metrics that we
gather from the machine
so that you can graph
out the CPU utilization
over the course of the job.
So it's there.
You can see it.
And then make your
determinations based on that.
And then, of course,
deadline load
balances the number of VMs
based on the load in the queue
so that you get the same
sort of efficiency you
do with a lot of the solutions
that you're seeing here,
where you're only amping
up the number of cores
that you really
need to do the work.
SRIKANTH BELWADI: And
I'd like to mention
the recent stack driver
product that's integrated
with the Google Cloud Platform.
But you can monitor not
just the Google instances
but across any of your
public cloud offering
if you are basically
using multiple clouds.
AUDIENCE: What is the back end
storage protocol that directory
is using, for example?
Where's the data
stored, and how is it
communicating with the VMs?
HUNTER WILLIAMS: So it
lives in a mostly a cluster
system with PD behind it.
We use Google's I/O scales
with how big the PD is.
So we get to the right size
to get the max I/O out of it.
And then we mount volume after
volume and cluster instance
after cluster instance.
AUDIENCE: So the back end
scales as the front end
is scaling too?
HUNTER WILLIAMS: Yes.
JACOB: If I can make a
suggestion regarding I/O. Maybe
the Google Cloud
Platform guys could
interface with the
Google Fiber guys
and get an LA deployment
pushed out here.
That would be pretty nice.
Thanks.
SRIKANTH BELWADI:
Thank you, Jacob.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: So I agree
with Google Fiber.
We need that in San Diego too.
It's terrible there.
So about all the software and
plug-ins, et cetera, et cetera.
I don't understand exactly
how the deployment works.
For example, in my setup
is Max, Fusion, V-Ray,
and a bunch of plug-ins.
So when you create the virtual
machine the first time,
you install the
software, and then stays
there, that virtual machine
available for you forever.
How does it work?
How does it apply updates,
et cetera, et cetera?
How does it work in
the case of Zinc?
I see that it works
with Maya and NUKE,
there's a possibility that it
will work with other software
too, or that's the limitation?
TODD PRIVES: I mean,
on the Zinc side,
it's billed as a
turnkey solution,
so we're looking at other host
applications in the future.
But essentially now,
when you submit a job
from an application,
we'll parse the scene,
make sure we have the proper
version of the software,
of the render, of the
plug-ins installed,
and have an image ready for you,
a preconfigured image for you,
based on that.
I would imagine it's the
same with Conductor as well.
So on software as
a service side,
that's how we have these
images ready for you.
Analyze your scene and
bake out one for you.
AUDIENCE: So would you
work at Max and Fusion?
TODD PRIVES: Currently we
don't support Max or Fusion.
But again, we're looking at all
content creation applications
in the future.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
JAMES COULTER: And so
in the case of deadline,
you would essentially
create your own OS image.
Right?
So exactly what you said.
You pull up an instance
of the operating
system that's provided
by Google, install
whatever you want on it.
Essentially you install
your same pipeline
that you would in your facility,
and then you save that out
as an image.
And then, when it's
spawning virtual machines,
it's just making copies of that
image for each virtual machine.
And so you can pretty much build
exactly what pipeline you want.
Of course, you have
to be a little bit
intelligent about
your bandwidth.
You don't want to do
anything too heavy
based on your bandwidth between
your local and your cloud.
But in a lot of cases,
a solution to that
is just push whatever
database or whatever
it is you think
you're talking to
or whatever piece is
slow up into the cloud
so that it can scale with
the rest of the stuff.
SRIKANTH BELWADI: OK.
Thanks, everyone.
All of these were very
interesting questions,
and I personally enjoyed
all these presentations.
So I really want to thank Todd,
Hunter, James, and Jordan.
If you looked at
the agenda closely,
the first half of our day was
primarily focused on rendering.
And the second
half, we're trying
to mix it up with storage,
a presentation on security,
and some of the interesting new
solutions around [INAUDIBLE]
and the last session on content
distribution and streaming.
I hope you'll all join
us again after lunch,
and we'll be back in
this room at 1 o'clock.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]